des dizaines de millions d'Américains
souffrent en ce moment à
cause de ce qu'ils s'inquiètent de
ce qui s'est passé à la Maison Blanche qui est
inacceptable pour moi
en ce moment, dans notre pays, nous avons un
problème, je ne sais pas si 73% de
votre temps est consacré à des
groupes haineux suprématistes blancs,
je ne sais pas, soixante-treize% de
votre temps est consacré aux
personnes qui ont peur dans les communautés de  ce
pays les américains sikhs les américains musulmans les
noirs américains le modèle de fait est
clair des menaces dans ce pays j'ai
mal où dick durbin m'a appelé j'ai eu des
larmes de rage quand j'ai entendu parler de cette
expérience lors de cette réunion et pour que vous
ne ressentiez pas cette blessure et que  douleur et
de rejeter certaines des questions de mes
collègues disant que j'ai déjà répondu à
cette série de questions alors que des dizaines de
millions d'Américains souffrent en ce
moment à cause de ce qui les
inquiète  à propos de ce qui s'est passé à la Maison Blanche
qui est inacceptable pour moi, il y a des
menaces dans ce pays, les gens
applaudissent, je reçois suffisamment de
menaces de mort pour connaître la réalité Kamla
reçoit des menaces de mort américaines pour connaître la
réalité
mazie reçoit suffisamment de menaces de mort pour
connaître la réalité et je '  j'ai un
président les États-Unis dont
je respecte la fonction qui parle des pays
d'origine mes concitoyens de la
manière la plus ignoble vous ne
vous souvenez pas vous ne vous souvenez pas des paroles de
votre commandant en chef je trouve que c'est
inacceptable M.  président je suis reconnaissant
de faire partie de ce comité je suis plus que
jamais heureux aujourd'hui je suis là merci